bonjour alexandre longo à merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on l'a vu après la rencontre entre les
syndicats le ministre de l'intérieur
hier un de vos collègues vos confrères
d'alliance police nationale a réagi le
dit je cite cette rencontre a le mérite
d'exister on sent tout de même derrière
cette phrase une petite pointe de
déception à ce que c'est un sentiment
que vous partagez aussi la première
chose c'est que monsieur castaner a pas
rencontré les syndicats de police mais
des syndicats de police triés sur le
volet par exemple nous nous sommes en
pointe sur le combat sur le racisme et
les dérives de certains collègues sur
les violences policières et nous n'avons
pas été invité bien évidemment donc ce
qui pose problème c'est qu'effectivement
une union c'est bien monsieur castaner
sait faire des réunions
après c'est les actes qui suivent qui
pose problème et il n'y en a pas et par
exemple dans votre sujet juste avant
vous interrogiez décès des syndicalistes
d'unités gp mais comment effectivement
leur réponse ne peut pas être autrement
que dire qu'ils ne comprennent pas qu'en
leur secrétaire général
il y a pas alors leur délégué général
avait dit [ __ ] c'est convenable il
ya à peine trois ans sur un plateau de
télé sans aucune sanction derrière et
après le racisme dans la police tue il
faut pas oublier nos collègues antillais
s'est suicidé en 2010 parce que c'est
archi le traité de [ __ ] et à force de
brimades régulières il en est arrivé à
se suicider de désespoir donc
effectivement il ya des racistes dans la
police voilà et maintenant le vrai
problème c'est que l'institution et les
syndicats qui est majoritaire à l'heure
actuelle ne veulent pas entendre parler
de ce problème
ils préfèrent fermer les yeux pour une
raisons d'image et ce qui est
catastrophique pour l'image de police
c'est que ces mêmes syndicats appellent
à dire le ministre du thé contre le
racisme
nous déposons les armes mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire au contraire demandons
une police propre et mettons à l'écart
cette minorité de collègues qui pose
problème
donc monsieur castetner attise les
divisions les problèmes et on espère
réellement qu'il va partir parce que le
problème est politique la volonté
politique de ne pas lutter réellement
contre le racisme dans la police c'est
le ministre qui veulent engager ou pas
la police les violences policières tout
ça est au coeur du débat
en ce moment quel est l'état d'esprit
des policiers en ce moment pas la même
chose que depuis des années
malheureusement mais ça s'amplifie avec
les images qui tournent sur les réseaux
sociaux mettant les captures d'écran qui
vont vite c'est qu'on a la pression
également que toute la police et
violente fait des dérives et utilise de
la feue la violence de façon illégitime
donc donc je rappelle que la violence
doit est nécessaire pour qu'on doit
arrêter un braqueur un terroriste pour
rétablir l'ordre sur des gens qui sont
en train de piller des boutiques donc
c'est nécessaire au cas par cas par
contre il est inadmissible d'utiliser la
violence face à des personnes qui ne
font rien ou qui n'ont il n'y a pas
nécessité de les maîtriser par des
méthodes violentes
donc du coup une fois de plus il ya tout
un amalgame qui est fait monsieur le
ministre est une fois de plus à côté de
toutes ces discussions parce qu'au début
par exemple sur le mouvement 10g et
jauni disait il y a aucune violence
policière était dans le déni
mais tant il fait d'exagération dans
l'autre sens on a l'impression que tous
les policiers sont des personnages
violents
donc en fait il n'y a pas de juste
milieu et ce qui sera intéressant c'est
que nos politiques au lieu d'utiliser la
police pour des besoins de communication
et de satisfaire l'opinion publique et
qui va dans telle grée et suivent le
sens du vent c'est une volonté de vérité
et de transparence sur la police et ça
c'est pas le cas ce n'est votée n'est
pas encore le carrot cake monsieur
castaner vu que l'igpn l'inspection
générale de la police nationale et la
police sur qui enquête sur elle-même
donc effectivement on n'avancera pas
pour le moment on essaye de reprendre
toutes les mauvaises méthodes qu'on déjà
utilisée dans le passé pour essayer de
faire du neuf
et ben non ça ne fait pas du neuf ça
fait juste qu'une fois de plus on a
l'impression que la police lave son
linge sale en famille non pour laver
lachalm et pour blanchir les hauteurs de
dérives et d'actes délictuels
on a vu hier plusieurs actions de
protestation je pense notamment à ces
images assez forte du côté de bobigny où
plusieurs policiers ont déposé leurs
menottes au sol il ya eu d'autres
actions ailleurs en france
est-ce que de mémoire de policier c'est
la première fois que vous vous voyez ça
et sk votre avis on est peut-être à
l'aube d'une véritable
cassure entre la police et son ministère
le ministère de l'intérieur
non il n'ya pas récemment enfin presti
récemment il ya en 2016 qui a eu les
évènements de viry-châtillon les
policiers étaient devant les
commissariats faisait des images de dos
il ya eu des manifestations nocturnes de
policiers dans paris le ministre de
l'époque était complètement dépassé et a
dû faire appel aux masses syndicat
majoritaire par un chantage odieux aux
mutations et aux avancements pour faire
rentrer tout le monde dans le rang
donc non la cassure eux n'est pas un
débat nouvelle elle existait déjà il
parle même si le la motivation de la
questure quand c'était viry-châtillon
c'est parce que nos collègues avaient
été brûlés dans leur voiture par des
délinquants et des criminels alors qu'il
surveillait une caméra de surveillance
c'est à dire que nous étions dans
quelque chose de complètement ahurissant
et les policiers n'avaient pas été
protégé à la hauteur de ce qu'ils
devaient dans le cadre de leur mission
aujourd'hui les manifestations ces
quelques centaines de collègues je tiens
à préciser sur plusieurs centaines sur
deux à peu près de 120 milles de forces
de l'ordre en france qui sont en train
de manifestants disent on ne comprend
pas pourquoi le ministre veut lutter
contre le racisme ont déjà il va pas
lutter contre le racisme pour de vrai la
preuve de délégués noah manoir a été
sanctionné pour avoir dénoncé des actes
de racisme en ayant été victimes
humaines de ces actes est là donc on
sait pour les mauvaises raisons
cirque on voudrait de la transparence
après effectivement si c'était un mot
d'ordre une suspicion généralisée contre
les policiers avec le soupçon à virer
monsieur questionnaire nous serions les
premiers à dire oui il faut dire que le
soupçon n'est pas une base légale en
france
par contre de dire que quand on veut
lutter contre le racisme on va dans la
rue parce qu'on est on se sent attaché
non c'est vrai que la version 10 mercier
monsieur le ministre pour une fois vous
faites une action dans le respect des
lois
merci beaucoup alexandre langlois
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur arte
france rappelle que vous êtes un
secrétaire général du syndicat de police
vigie merci beaucoup merci à vous